Allora la prima è a quanto strana perché
c'è sta tizia qua che sembra che stia
toccando la patata a quest'altra tizia
ma anche te che fai la foto ma santo è
Dio ma diglielo che c'ha il braccio che
sembra il suo eh Anche questa è
stranissima questa è bellissima perché è
tipo sembra troppo il culo della tipa
dietro e la cosa più bella della foto
non è neanche questa Ma quanto cazzo
figo quello posso fare una domanda ma il
tizio nella foto come c'è finito in
questa posizione lasciamo stare il gatto
che fa karate Cat
questo è stupendo è bellissimo quando
sei in ritardo per la telecronaca è
porco il tachimetro parcheggio in tribu